aux invités ils sont en direct avec ton
laurent alexandre et essayiste et
chirurgiens et rémi tales cofondateur du
collectif peuple libre
messieurs bonjour et merci à d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors on le sait
désormais être vaccinés n'empêche pas
d'être contaminés de contaminer
d'ailleurs mais protège contre les
formes graves laurent alexandre
comprenez vous que ce point précis
finalement donne du grain à moudre aux
plus réfractaires
la situation est en train de s'améliorer
ce qu'on voit c'est une diminution très
importante de la mobilisation il ya
chaque samedi de moins en moins de monde
et il y a de plus en plus de gens
vaccinés on vient de dépasser 50
millions donc en réalité on est en phase
d'amélioration sanitaires on espère
qu'il n'y aura pas d'aggravation avec
l'arrivée du froid en octobre mais même
s'il ya une vague le niveau de
protection qu'on a avec le vaccin
devrait éviter qu'on ait beaucoup de
morts puisque les toutes dernières
études montrent que le vaccin diminue
par 11 le risque de mourir du cosy de
toutes classes d'âge confondues donc en
réalité on est en train de sortir de la
crise on va une président l'a annoncé
alléger le pass sanitaires dans les
régions qui vont mieux dans les semaines
qui viennent donc on voit une queue de
manifestation et de mobilisation
principalement des gilets jaunes et de
l'extrême extrême droite et à l'extrême
droite de 2,2 de marine le pen puisque
c'est philippe oas lino et puis du
poignant qui sont les principaux meneurs
de cette mobilisation donc globalement
cette mobilisation elle est à
contretemps parce qu on est en train
tout doucement de sortir de la crise
grâce à la vaccination
même si la vaccination protège beaucoup
de la mort et ne protège pas
complètement de la contamination alors
on a des manifestantes qui viennent seul
un indépendamment omis mobilisation
parisienne et à travers toute la france
invité de c'est vrai qu'on a une
mobilisation a peut-être qui diminue en
terme de deux personnes qui chaque
samedi descendre dans la rue mon atout
même une mobilisation qui perdure
puisque ça fait 10 samedi on le rappelle
c'est une mobilisation historique par
son ampleur par sa durée dans la
diversité de ce qu'il a qui la
rejoignent le mouvement se porte très
bien rassuré le docteur laurent
alexandre avec lequel je suis très
heureux de débattre ce soir merci à
alerter france parce que laurent
alexandre avec lequel je suis en
désaccord à peu près surtout a au moins
le mérite d'aller jusqu'au bout de ce
qu'est le communisme dans son organisme
son racisme social son cynisme absolu
jusqu'au refus de traiter les personnes
malades laurent vers lexandre à une
autre caractéristique c'est de s'être
aussi trompé sur à peu près tout depuis
le début de cette crise et notamment sur
la vaccination massive évidemment je ne
vois pas son point de vue sur les effets
supposés bénéfiques de la vaccination
vous aviez promis docteur de manger
votre chapeau aussi en israël la
situation s'est améliorée suite à la
vaccination massive nous ne vous avons
pas encore vu le faire avant que je suis
venu avec mon agenda pour prendre match
voilà de la cérémonie a dû grand festin
du chapeau de laurent alexandre plus
sérieusement il faudra qu'on en parle
mais ce qu'on voit c'est que dans les
pays où vous avez une vaccination
massive en israël par exemple la
situation est aujourd'hui catastrophique
laurent alexandre voulez c'est bien
évidemment répondre à rémi tales
j'avais dit que j'étais persuadé que la
vaccination casserait la troisième vague
en israël et c'est le cas
la troisième vague avant le variant
delta a été complètement cassé en israël
aujourd'hui il ya une nouvelle vague de
contamination avec relativement peu de
morts parce que la protection contre les
formes grâce par le vaccin reste
heureusement forte alors rémi tales dit
que je fais partie des gens qui se
posent aux traitements plus personne sur
terre ne croit que l'hydroxyde leur
quine marche plus personne sur terre ne
croit que l'a63 micinn marche plus
personne sur terre ne pense que
l'ivermectine marche plus personne sur
terre ne pense que le zinc marche même
les médecins qui étaient pro raul ne
prescrivent plus d'ide roxy chloroquine
aujourd'hui donc l'idée sur laquelle il
y a traitement qui marche et que des
méchants gouvernements dans le monde
entier sauf au pakistan au nigeria et en
egypte empêche de traiter est une idée
objectivement délirante si les
traitements marchait nous médecins ont
les prescrire est pourquoi voudriez vous
que la quasi-totalité des médecins à
part quelques chars bateau ne
prescrivent pas l'ivermectine hydroxy
chloroquine et là ses premiers signes
pour une raison très simple c'est que
tous les essais cliniques ont montré que
ces molécules ne marchait pas contre le
coc ville et si on prend l'hydroxyde
chloroquine sujet depuis beaucoup étudié
pour avoir une dose efficace contre le
virus de l'hydroxyde chloroquine il
faudrait cent fois l'anneau actuel il
faudrait une dose absolument mortel pour
un organisme comme est le corps humain
donc vous partez de l'idée que les
méchants médecins dans le monde entier
empêche de traiter avec sid roxy clan
keane vous oubliez juste que tout à
démontrer que les dropkick leur qui ne
marchait pas il faut être franchement
tordu pour penser que tous les médecins
du monde vole la mort de leurs malades
en leur refusant des drogues site leur
quine c'est une idée franchement qui est
extrêmement bizarre il pourrait y avoir
quelques médecins méchant refusant le
traitement miracle à leurs patients mais
tous les médecins du monde sont dans
cette situation il faudrait un énorme
complot mondial pour que tous les
médecins soient coordonnées pour refuser
ce traitement miracle qu'est le
protocole raul puis le zinc et libère
mes coups qui sont les nouvelles folies
des complotistes cofidis très vite elle
oui alors les maisons bien plus simple
qui explique l'absence totale quasi
totale de prescription de ces
traitements que c'est qu'ils ont été
interdits et qu'ils ont été retirés des
autorisations de prescription au tout
début de la crise pour des raisons que
chacun donc chacun pourra juger sur
l'hydroxyde de retourner l'ivermectine 2
quelques chiffres identiques lourdines
aujourd'hui vous avez 287 études qui ont
démontré son efficacité probable dans le
traitement du cobp id la probabilité
pour que ce résultat positif soit le
fruit du hasard et de 1 sur 359 three
lions pour liebherr machines
soixante quatre études ont démontré son
efficacité et la probabilité pour que
cette efficacité démontrée par les
études ne soient que le fruit du hasard
et de 1 sur 220 en ce 2 milliards juste
un exemple en inde en inde deux états
ont choisi des stratégies différentes de
lutte contre le co lead vous allez
l'uttar pradesh que soigner avec les
nerfs médecine et vous avez le
maharashtra qui a vu les jets la
vaccination est le rêve des débits dans
l'uttar pradesh 220 millions d'habitants
22 1845 à ce jour les échos vite ça
représente 0 01 % de la population et
dans le maharashtra 130 millions
d'habitants
138000 décès liés au collier de 5-0 ou
bien vous le 11 pour son application
c'est un rapport de 1 à 10 en république
tchèque depuis qu'on a levé
l'interdiction de prescription
l'ivermectine vous avez un ratio de mort
du co vide par habitant qui est cette
fois inférieur à celui de la france
alors que vous soyez cher docteur de
bonne foi en prétendant que les
traitements ne soigne pas je ne le crois
tout à fait et vous connaissez cette
fameuse théorie du rasoir de cannes il
faut jamais prêté à la malveillance qui
peut être attribué évidemment pas dans
votre cas mais à la bêtise en revanche
oui ces traitements soit nous montre le
corner virus vous avez un certain nombre
de conflits d'intérêts chez les médecins
chez les médecins signataires les 93
médecins signataires de la tribune pour
la vaccination obligatoire de soignants
vous totalisez lui fit lui millions
d'euros de liens d'intérêts avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique
bon je suis pas dans une logique
marxiste si vous voulez pas du tout même
mais il y en a il faut aussi accepter de
voir ce que l'on voit comme disait péguy
et aujourd'hui ce que l'on voit c'est
que vous avez des gens qui explique que
le traitement ne fonctionne pas parce
que ces personnes là sont liées à des
laboratoires qui ont tout intérêt à
positionner de nouvelles molécules pour
traiter contre le commis de 19 alors
laurent alexandre je vais vous a laissé
répondre puis après je voudrais revenir
avec vous messieurs sur un chiffre
officiel tout d'abord laurent alexandre
oui alors d'abord je voudrais dire je
n'ai aucun conflit d'intérêts d'aucune
sorte sur ce sujet là et que je ne
touche pas un centime des fabricants de
médicaments
pour ou contre la chloroquine à contre
le coc vider les fabricants de vaccins
contre le culte alors ce qu'il faut quoi
parce que je connais très bien ces
études j'ai beaucoup étudié depuis deux
ans et j'ai passé 20 ans de ma vie à
faire de la pharmacologie c'est à dire
l'évaluation des médicaments et j'ai
fait et participer à des centaines
d'études d'évaluation du médicament dans
ma vie donc c'est un sujet que je
connais à fond les études dont vous
parlez sont toutes des études pourri le
nigéria le bangladesh dans des pays où
il n'ya aucune tradition et idéologique
être santé publique ce sont des études
qui sont faites sans vérification
statistiques et donc effectivement on
accumule plein d'études pourri qui
démontre que la chloroquine et l'idée
rythme et il marche mais ça n'est pas le
cas et je le répète il faudrait vraiment
un complot gigantesque que pour pour que
tous les médecins du monde et décidé de
sacrifier leur malade on ne leur
prescrivant pas ces molécules si ces
molécules étaient efficaces qui est un
médecin pourri par ci par là pourquoi
pas mais la totalité du corps médical
qui refuse d'utiliser ces médicaments
vraiment vraiment je le répète il faut
être très tordu pour penser que la
totalité du corps médical est acheté et
vendu et a décidé de sacrifier les
malades sur l'autel de la collaboration
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
franchement c'est une vision qui est
complètement fautes mais je ne vous
votre vision est celle là vous êtes
persuadé qu'elle est une molécule
miracle et que tous les méchants
médecins et toutes les administrations
dans le monde refuse d'utiliser ces
molécules miracle vous verrez dans un an
ou deux quand tout ça sera décantée à
kehl à quel point on se rendra compte
que ces molécules ne marchait pas
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la plupart des
complotistes parle principalement de
liberec tine parce que tout le monde
sait bien que le protocole ne marche pas
et hydroxy chloroquine ne me ne marche
pas donc on a vu les gens ap de la
chloroquine ali drogue cyclo rockin
dropsy chloroquine plus assis trop
missiles au zinc à l'ivermectine et vous
allez voir ce n'est pas fini au fur et à
mesure on se rend compte que c'est
molécule miracle ne marche pas les
complotistes vont s'attacher à des
nouveaux doudou à des nouvelles
molécules ils vont trouver des nouveaux
complots imaginaires honorons alexandre
c'est vrai c'est certaines études ans
sont prendre avec des pincettes d'autres
en ont été pré elles se sont en tout cas
avérés l'avenir nous le dira rémi tales
j'aimerais revenir avec vous en tout cas
sur un chiffre officiel car elle nous
vient du gouvernement manifestement 80%
peut-être que ce chiffre a diminué
maintenant on va dire la majorité des
hospitalisés sont vaccinés rémi tales
pouvez vous revenir avec nous sur ce
chiffre
alors on déjà le chiffre officiel venant
du gouvernement je sais je j'ai été
diplômé en politique publique je fais
des affaires publiques à titre
professionnel
j'ai plutôt une confiance naturelle dans
la parole de l'état n'est plus du tout
depuis 18 mois les chiffres officiels du
gouvernement que nous explique vous avez
quelques milliers de manifestants à
paris alors que l'on avait sans doute eu
plusieurs millions dans toute la france
bon donc ce chiffre ressort de n'importe
où et il contredit en plus la réalité de
notre pays est encore une fois regarder
ce qui se passe aux etats unis regardez
ce qui se passe en israël où les gens
qui sont en réanimation aujourd'hui pour
pour des formes graves tu copies qu'ils
ne sont très majoritairement des
personnes qui ont été qui ont été
vaccinées et on ne parle même pas là des
gens qui souffrent d'effets secondaires
quoi sur les cycles menstruels lui
myocardite
notre jour le jerusalem post titrait
qu'après avoir vacciné deux milliards de
terriens les chercheurs s'intéresser
enfin aux effets secondaires des vaccins
arn messagers sur le sur le long terme
tout ça est une immense expérience donc
on ne sait pas grand chose et je
maintiens que ces traitements soigne
alors peut-être qu'ils ne sont pas la
panacée à l'inversé le beaucoup d'études
qui ont été faits pour discréditer les
traitements celle par exemple d'un
françois xavier lescure conseiller
spécial colite d'olivero qui lui
administrer de banksy chloroquine à des
macaques elle pourrait évidemment en
conclure qu'elle était inefficace contre
le coc vie de 19 on avait beaucoup donné
l'identique le rock inn à des malades en
fin de vie alors qu'on sait qu'il roxy
tueur au kiné et efficace au début des
symptômes du duduk au lied et donc oui
moi je fais le point de vue évidemment
contraire à celui de dr laurent
alexandre je pense quand on aura laisser
décanter tout ça on se rendra compte de
l'immense scandale sanitaire de ces
vingt derniers mois et à nouveau il
s'agit pas de dire que tout le monde est
corrompu et que tout le monde est
méchant mais les médecins de bonne foi
lisent le quotidien du médecin et le
quotidien du médecin relais des
informations qui sont aujourd'hui des
informations complètement erronée enfin
si la vaccination permettait de résoudre
cette crise on l'aurait su allez
demander aux israéliens devraient poser
les questions docteur laurent alexandre
docteur on entend très peu parler des
cas de copie de 19 et de mortalité en
afrique subsaharienne est ce que vous
pouvez l'expliquer alors que l'afrique
subsaharienne est très peu vaccinés
alors dr laurent alexandre g vous
vraiment vous laisser rapide mais très
très rapidement je suis désolé on est
vraiment pressé par le temps pressait
c'est très très simple la médiane d'âge
au niger ses 15 ans l'a mis là lydiane
d'âge au sénégal ses 19 ans quand on a
des populations aussi jeunes qu'on a en
afrique noire on a effectivement très
peu mort du co vide les l'afrique
subsaharienne et est la zone
géographique sur terre où la population
la plus jeune vous rendez compte au
niger 15 ans d'âge médian évidemment la
quasi totalité de la population est
enfant adolescent très très jeunes
adultes donc oui avec des moyennes avec
des médianes d'âge à 15 ans comme le
niger eh ben on a quasiment zéro mort du
co zid parce qu'on sait bien que les
jeunes font peu de morts donc il est
tout à fait logique il ya très peu de
morts en afrique noire ça s'explique par
l'épidémiologie de la secte noir il
savait bien que l'afrique noire sera
passé en peu d'années de 500 millions
d'habitants à 4 milliard deux cents
millions d'habitants cette explosion de
la population elle se traduit par un âge
moyen en afrique noire qui est
extraordinairement faibles et qui est
une protection immense contre le coc
vite donc voilà l'explication
épidémiologique à votre petite devinette
quand on a une médiane d'âge à 15 ans on
a zéro mort du coup on a zéro mort du co
vide vous voyez que tout s'explique par
la science
pressé par le temps messieurs en tout
cas merci pour vos analyses en a tous
les deux messieurs avec des avis très
très différente des avis qui bien sûr
m'engage que vous docteur alexandre vous
êtes un chirurgien essayiste rémi tales
de lettres cofondateur du collectif
peuple libre merci à vous deux